okay this is part question part opinion
in podcast 13 you stated effectively not
explicitly that jiu-jitsu is the martial
art that takes the most time to become
proficient I disagree and here's why as
a wrestler I've been able to pick up
jiu-jitsu in a matter of about two
months to the point where I can submit a
blue belt here and there and mostly
control purple belt possibly there is
white skill ranged along belts which I
only roll with lower level players I
might just be a bad teacher but I've not
I've not had as much success teaching
jiu-jitsu guys to wrestle after the same
amount of time they're after the same
amount of time there may be a low high
high school wrestling level I found it
extremely difficult to teach new
disciplines to shoot penetrate with
their hips or effectively use their hips
to defend us or scramble possibly my
sample size is too small to form an
accurate opinion but I'm curious of your
thoughts on the topic thanks love
listening you learned so yeah I guess
when I said that I should have said
grappling in general which is definitely
harder to achieve a basic level of
competence in rather than striking now
don't get me wrong you take a skilled
boxer they will destroy an unskilled
boxer you take a skilled muy Thai guy
they will destroy an unskilled muy Thai
guy do
you've changed good more Thai people
before right the first person that I
ever did that with that was a skilled
muy Thai legit skilled Muay Thai it was
like black Bell versus white belt right
yeah I would think about throwing a kick
at him and he would check it right and
then he would throw a kick at me before
I even knew what was happening right
there that much better they can see your
hips they move it's the same same thing
with boxing if you go against a good
boxer they'll Jack you up in that sport
right in that sport you will get works
so now that being said a good wrestler
is a good grappler you are a good
grappler and that's why you're able to
pick up jujitsu very quickly because
rest
is grappling which is jiu-jitsu there
are there differences yes there
absolutely are differences but it's like
longboard surfing and short board
surfing if you're or baseball and
softball if you played baseball in
college when you get out on the the the
office softball team you're a killer
that's the way it is not it's cuz you
played soft but you played baseball you
didn't play technically softball it's
the same thing with with wrestling and
as far as the fact that it doesn't take
long to learn if you're a high level
wrestler to learn jujitsu yes absolutely
you'll learn it very quickly look at the
history of the UFC Dan Severn Mark
Coleman Kevin Randleman Randy Koecher
Tito all those high-level Russell's and
that's the history because guess what
high level wrestlers are there right now
- John Jones
DC it's it's wrestlers it's wrestlers
and wrestlers now are there other guys
that come in and fill it but the the the
I would say the majority base is
wrestling you know so now you also have
to look at speaking of history you have
to look at the early ufc's or you go to
any gym in the fact is the fact is a jiu
jitsu only guy beats a wrestling only
guy in a fight nine times out of ten
that's the way it is that now if the
wrestler can learn very quickly but if
the wrestler only knows wrestling and
the jiu-jitsu guy only knows jujitsu the
jujitsu guy is going to win simply
because the wrestler doesn't know how to
finish the fight he doesn't know how to
finish it he doesn't have any submission
holds to finish a fight so can they
occasionally nine times you know one
time out of ten or whatever get
something and and yes that can happen
but and and also I'm not talking about
if you take a NCAA wrestler and you put
them against the white belt or
maybe even a blue belt there's a chance
that the blue belt can't submit him the
guy's just too strong
that's if he has some awareness if he
has no awareness whatsoever he's gonna
get tapped out yeah and if you watch the
early ufc's that's exactly what happened
you know the wrestlers they might get
position but they were getting choked
they were getting tapped and you go to
any gym right now you have a tough
wrestler walk in that doesn't know any
jiu-jitsu he's gonna get tapped out I
mean for instance right now at our gym
we got a really good wrestler named
Taylor Johnson and I'll bring his name
up because he eats I can remember it all
cuz it's all been recent he's been
training now for less than a year when
he first came in he was getting tapped
out you know that's the way it is he's a
phenomenal wrestler two months later he
wasn't getting tapped out six months
later he's tapping people out so that's
what happens but if you take physically
kind of close people and you put pure
wrestling against pure jiu-jitsu
jiu-jitsu who's gonna win now there's
also another thing that you're probably
noticing in this situation and that is
that wrestling wrestling selects for
athleticism right wrestling selects for
athleticism and for you to be
competitive in wrestling you need to be
strong quick athletic agile all those
things are important and I've seen that
you know with the the school where my
kids wrestle and you see it what it's
like when you get a strong athletic kid
and how they're able to execute moves
better than someone that's not that good
of an athlete and so wrestling does that
wrestling is selective so if you
wrestled guess what you're a really good
athlete you and if you did well
wrestling or he wrestled for a long time
you developed that athleticism because
you had to be explosive you had to train
hard so that's that also blue belts you
look at a blue belt a blue belt is
basically a person that's been doing
jiu-jitsu for a year maybe two years
right so that's the same thing
as a lower-level high school wrestler
right a low-level high school wrestler
was a guy that didn't start wrestling
until he was a freshman year started
wrestling well that's a low-level high
school wrestler and guess what he's
getting beat so you should be if you're
a good wrestler you should be able to
once you understand the basic principles
of jujitsu you should be able to beat
blue belts because they're a year into
the game that's the way it is
yeah you take a competitive wrestler and
you go against somebody that's you know
seven years in and now they're a brown
belt well that's that's a competitive
high school wrestler
that's a senior and he started training
in sixth grade that's seven eight years
go against a seven or eight year
jiu-jitsu guy you've got now you've got
a good match and likely legit to guys
gonna win now again if you take know if
you take a pure wrestler versus of pure
jiu-jitsu the juicy guys gonna win all
day all day so you know there's no
denying and like I just said there's a
reason that wrestling is the the premier
skill set in the UFC that predicts
champions no doubt about it
it is a great and incredible martial art
I I wish that that wrestling had kept
its roots as catch wrestling and still
had submission holds and all that
because it would just completely change
the game but it doesn't so you have to
add them later there's also something
else too where I think that I think that
people in general wrestling's not for
everybody mmm right it's a very hard
sport and I think that people avoid that
grind of as far as as far as the okay
you're gonna get good at wrestling now
how much it's a guy now I'm gonna make
you good at wrestling jujitsu guys have
void the grind
I shouldn't say all of them but some
often do do two guys avoid the grind of
the takedowns and the intensity of
wrestling they're not looking for that
that's one of the things that makes it
so appealing to a very broad range of
people is that you can train it at a at
a mellower pace right and that's also
why if you go do jiu-jitsu tournaments
wrestler
do really well in jiu-jitsu tournaments
because they understand the intensity of
rounds of limited time of Smashing
someone of going all-out jiu-jitsu guy
that's been traded in the gym
name ready for that first tournament
there's no jiu-jitsu guy in the gym that
goes to the first tournament and says
yeah that was just like what I thought
it was me like no they not used to that
intensity they're not ready for it so I
mean and of course not taking away from
jiu-jitsu guys that train like Mad Men
with total intensity and get after it's
super hard to go as those guys exist as
well
and also last little thing on this there
are also some wrestlers that don't adapt
to the slower pace of jiu-jitsu they
can't adapt to that and they don't adapt
to the slower pace of MMA and so they
their whole career they gas out and
there's plenty of pro MMA fighters UFC
that have come in high-level wrestlers
that they couldn't ever quite make the
transition to MMA so you know bottom
line these are these are points that I
pretty much agree with that the that
this this guy made and wrestling's
awesome I think it's a great base I
think it's it's a form of grappling and
it complements jiu-jitsu and Egypt
jiu-jitsu complements it and I wish that
it was one sport yeah but it's not so
you have to do both yeah and it seems
like like two because he was originally
not complaining wasn't complaining but
his premise was that you know jiu-jitsu
is is not in fact the hardest one to
master you know wrestling he's implying
that wrestling is harder to master you
know because he taught jiu-jitsu guys
wrestling and they didn't pick it up
right it was kind of in jujitsu you can
break all kinds of wrestling rules in
jiu-jitsu yeah and but wrestling guys
when they'll come in if they they have
to learn to break some wrestling rules
otherwise it's gonna be their detriment
sure a lot of them a lot of them carry
over a lot of
a lot of the strengthen but man if a
wrestler can't break the rule to to go
to his back there's a lot of rest the
wrestles will give up their back all day
there's they don't want to go on their
back you know and that's why they're
gonna get choked all the time but if
like Taylor you that's a good example
Pro Hill fucked he broke that rule quick
and that's why he's so good cuz he can
expand his mind and break that rule so
but consider the jiu-jitsu guy right now
he has to learn all they see so he has
to essentially and not so much break the
rule you can probably break some rules
you know but not going back whatever but
you just think I doesn't have to break
any jiu-jitsu rules necessarily case in
point how much time and effort am I
gonna put into learning a takedown
correctly when it barely decides the
match exactly there's a mental there's a
mental gap into the desire for knowledge
because if I if you take me down cool
I'm gonna get in you I'm gonna be you're
not gonna pass my guard whereas when a
wrestler shows up he has to learn this
stuff otherwise he's losing he's getting
tapped out he's getting choked yeah so
that's a great great point there yeah
very true so yeah you don't have to you
know and even when you say okay Jiu
Jitsu should focus more on takedowns and
it's really cool and you should
definitely focus on the takedown so you
got to learn them and it's very
important but at the back your mind as a
jiu-jitsu guy I'm like just bull guard
yeah I don't really care if you take me
down it's okay or and then now we're
talking about in this case we're come
out saying that me personally because I
don't like potentially but and here's
the thing to even add to that even if
you're considering the comparison of
wrestling and jiu-jitsu take the
takedown situation take not all
takedowns are quote unquote wrestling
takedowns yeah I can be like okay I can
not learn wrestling at all and still be
good at takedowns if I learn judo or
fight you know if I learn something so
again so it goes it's basically you're
taking something really vast with a lot
of easy ways to maneuver around certain
techniques and still be vastly
successful and then you're basically
saying okay let's take that
person who has that approach and narrow
it down to this much more difficult
approach and way less effective approach
essentially is the vastness of grappling
I can still be successful in grappling
without learning XYZ wrestling moves and
then you want to teach them these XYZ
wrestling moves probably some that can
go against you especially when it comes
to energy energy conservation and all
this other stuff that's why a guy maybe
yeah who might be difficult to learn
that but how you said there's a gap in
the motivation there's a difficult to
wanna learn or kick or care about
learning this thing when it's gonna
serve me less in my grappling no doubt
you can just look at the human facts of
jiu-jitsu there's a reason why takedowns
are not emphasized very much energy to
at a normal academy in normal academy
they do not have the focus on takedowns
like wrestling wrestling in wrestling
the takedown wins you doesn't win you
the match on record but that's a huge
part of wrestling is getting the
takedowns jiu-jitsu it's it's a little
tiny percentage of the match give you
two points yeah but it doesn't mean
anything to me because I'm gonna submit
you yeah in just the nature of the game
you know wrestling is takedown pin
there's more to it I understand but
jiu-jitsu is just submit the guy you
know soju gets it in in a way it's like
just just get it to the ground you can
hit off your back you can win them from
the top you can wear a wrestling son
like that
yeah I know people literally pull guard
and then win from there back on top zero
in the match and so so the fact that you
can pull guard gives you this entire out
to get away from doing takedowns and you
can still be victorious yeah very very
often yeah and that goes along with
these even these techniques that he
mentioned like you know you know see hit
basically that there's there's a lot of
moves in there there big moves big moves
and they do help you but like I said
that they're just they're simply not
necessary you know I mean any physical
move is helpful to know and
to defend whether it be from offensive
you know or defense position but again
if you're trying to narrow it down and
teach these guys who their approach and
their knowledge comes from the vastness
of grappling yeah and you want to narrow
it down to this thing it may or may not
work you know and it may or may not
serve you it could work against you but
here let's try to learn this real hard
yeah you can have that gap in motives
you actually don't care about the
takedowns yeah and I'm gonna go on
record now as saying this just because
jujitsu doesn't focus on takedowns
doesn't mean that you shouldn't focus
you should learn takedowns you need to
know takedowns from a self-defense
perspective from an MMA perspective
takedowns wrestling you have to do it I
mean that's why my kids wrestle you know
it's because I didn't wrestle and I hate
that fact because I go against like he's
saying you know I go against a good high
school wrestler
it's hard for me to take him to the
ground you know you get somebody that
wrestled in college I know what's I know
I'm not good now I I have developed good
takedown defense over the years and it's
actually takedown offense because I have
offensive ways of defending takedown you
know I'm gonna throw submissions but I
can't go back in time and go through the
the training that you get when you're a
high school wrestler and and college
wrestler I can't do that I can't do it I
mean I just don't have the time and the
motivation to do it because I'm in the
same boat as as you know what the guy
that you're just talking about how much
time am I going to focus on takedowns I
know I go against a college wrestler
he's taking me down I go against a good
high school wrestler there's a good
chance he's taking me down yeah so how
much time and effort I mean I could
spend the next five years I could go
through a competitive circuit I could
join the wrestling club but am I gonna
do that right now is that time effective
or do I just want to get better at Jiu
Jitsu and then have access to the rest
of the grappling spectrum that you just
talked about well it's an obvious choice
I'm gonna focus on the spectrum that has
the most the most
application in every situation I'm gonna
be in yeah so if you if you get the
chance wrestle wrestle as much as you
can learn your takedowns drill your
takedowns put your kids into wrestling
jujitsu for sure put your kids into
wrestling you know they don't have to
worry about it then yeah the fact
remains some people they don't want that
beef you know where you gotta go and
wrestle you're a man that's hard you
know and even like a wrestling you can
have a wrestling style to your jujitsu
you know but again if you don't want it
you know who didn't wrestle Craig Craig
Baker Aker ya didn't wrestle ya you
ready you'll be like where did you
wrestle in college is what you thinking
he's pure Jiu Jitsu yeah didn't wrestle
in college yeah didn't wrestle in high
school didn't even wrestle in high
school he feels like a total wrestler
when you're with him and his takedowns
are great yeah and there's some
Brazilian guys that have come up that
you know Brazilian UFC fighters that are
very good wrestles that never wrestled
before they have really good takedowns
yeah and but you know you're gonna even
have to worry if it work for that and
these kids that come out of high school
yeah that wrestled in high school they
got it yeah that work has an input yes
gift that they got yeah but for these
guys and back to the question for these
guys that he's trying to teach and he
totally says like it could be my sample
size I understand yeah that's a good
point actually
but because the sample size be big you
can get guys like Craig they'll pick
that stuff up real quick but at the end
of the day when it comes to as he put it
when it comes time to shoot penetrate
with their hips or effectively use their
hips to defend or scramble you can omit
all of those things from a jiu-jitsu guy
and he can still win and beats
vasin successful you know so scramble mm
scrambles a questionable one yeah to be
almost devil yeah but again I mean you
know we've moved you scrambling is a
very good valuable thing to have in
jiu-jitsu yeah much more valuable than
you know being able to penetrate on the
shop yeah yeah agree but yeah wrestlers
right that's a weird that's such an
interesting bro I roll with this I feel
bad that I forget his name but I roll
with him every time I see him and he
swallowing me a given may be 165 maybe
and but an awesome wrestler new guy -
under one year and his game is resting
but he's like high-level rest and also
if I play the wrestling game and I know
I know wrestling like I'm solid I can
wrestle against good wrestlers maybe not
Taylor but good wrestlers so I can play
and I'm bigger than him
you know so if I go and wrestle to
wrestle this guy bro he liked it you run
game on you yeah I'll run his game push
but if I just slow down in my mind be ok
he's a wrestler it's just yeah let's
work around the wrestling ah no problem
yeah you know but once the once he if he
can give up the wrestling rules you know
you know yeah but he because he has that
athleticism he switches hips like all
quick base just like like he's built
into the ground that's how good his base
is you know it's a yeah wrestling yeah
and I guess from a human nature
perspective here for you to apply this
to other situations in life think about
when you're trying to get people to do
things
think about the motivation that they
have in their head not not motivation of
like let's go but not the actual the
actual mental motivation of what they're
gonna gain from what you're trying to
give them and do they see the reason of
why it's important yeah you gotta play
across the board jiu-jitsu the life
wrestling is life wrestling is grappling
rappeling is like